[Music]
he's known for keeping order in the
House of Commons no easy feat but what
does the speaker think about the current
culture in Westminster we take a tour
around sir Lindsay hoyle's parliamentary
home
[Music]
good evening over the past few months
British politics has been tested like
never before scandals infighting
resignations resulting in a revolving
door of prime ministers at number 10 all
this with a backdrop of a cost of living
crisis which sees families struggling to
pay energy and food bills and now the
steepest interest rate rise in over 30
years this turmoil has caused anger at
the heart of Westminster where decision
makers debate the issues that affect all
of ours in the houses of Parliament the
person in charge of keeping it all in
check is Sir Lindsay Hoyle the Speaker
of the House of Commons let's see him in
action
I invite sir Lindsay Hoyle to take the
chair of the house
[Applause]
I stand firm that I hope this house will
be once a great respected house not just
in here but across the world I love the
eyeball to eyeball I love the excitement
of the gym I love the power of the chair
hold up hold up I said to the unknown
General
I will not tolerate such Behavior
if you want to go out go out now but if
you stand again and Lord you out sit
down a minute
this house will not be taken for granted
it is not right for everybody to be
breathed it's not more important to go
on the news in the morning it's more
important to come here and why the
honorable resentment will not tell us
[Applause]
I'm not going to be challenging maybe
the prime minister's contract but in
this house I'm in charge
sir Lindsay Hoyle
um the Speaker of the House of Commons
Mr speaker thank you for joining us on
the show we're going to talk to you
about politics Parliament your political
career
um but before we do that you're going to
give me the political version of look
through the keyhole and show me your pad
the sort of palatial surroundings of uh
Mr Speaker but I think we've got a Guy
Fawkes theme haven't we to stop I think
nothing more appropriate let's let's
start off look at the key here yeah this
is the key That Guy Fawkes had to try
and ensure he could get his Gunpowder
Plot underway you know and this is the
history that you've got within
Parliament and you know everything you
loot there's always a piece of History
somewhere speakers do have nice
accommodation don't they you have the
speaker's house can you
tell us what this place is what this
part of the Palace of Westminster is
that this is speaker size speaker's
office we're walking through knowing to
the State departments the speakers rooms
for entertainment that we use for
different events and I think that's
what's important is about opening this
up yeah and what we've tried to is
ensure you know we've got the public
coming in as well you know at night when
parliament's all gone packed up do you
just come in here and have a disco I
mean do you come and hang out in here
the 40th anniversary for Harriet Harman
40 years of being an MP the longest
serving female and the mother of the
house mother of the house can you show
me this because um I think we're going
to jump on this aren't we we are so not
doing that I know uh can you explain uh
to our viewers what what why is there a
bed in here what is this room
this is a royal bed this is the bed and
the Royal stair room so on the night of
the coronation you want somewhere where
the king can get to The Abbey without
interruption and the nearest place to
sleep is the step bedroom and the state
bed is here in case King Charles on his
coronation
on the Night Before It's Made available
to him
do you predict that King Charles will
come and stay here the night before next
year I remind him I've got his bed ready
what did he say
oh interesting I think was the word and
of course it as he says there are many
quirks in history and not more so than
there's having the state bed always
ready and Mr Speaker if I um had come
down from Mars and I had no idea uh
what the speaker was or what you did
what can you can you how would you
explain your job to me
I think I think the issue umpire referee
somebody who holds the house in good
order and I think I think you know that
that's the thing isn't it what do I do
so basically we've got to ensure the
business goes through I want to ensure
there's good scrutiny from the
opposition and I want to make sure the
government legislation is brought to the
floor of the house so I'm the referee
I'm the Umpire about trying to get
ensure the business goes through but
also it's scrutinized and you have a
responsibility for the Palace of
Westminster as well do you I do indeed
the House of Commons is my domain and
it's a domain that's not only is it a
privilege to be the speaker but actually
I have a huge responsibility one is
security uh we've seen the tragic
attacks on Jill Cox and David Amish who
lost their lives serving as a member the
attack on Parliament you know the
terrorist State we've been through that
and those are the worst moments those
are the moments that keep you awake
because I have that responsibility and
we've got to make sure we do everything
we can to protect democracy and protect
a poem and just just to finish off on
Guy Fawkes and obviously it's the
anniversary we've got bonfire night Guy
Fawkes did not succeed obviously in the
Gunpowder Plot 36 barrels of explosives
were put in the cellar one the under the
House of Lords yes he did not succeed it
did not succeed and I think that's the
thing isn't it that we've got to make
sure democracy thrives and survives it's
people who don't believe in our values
always worried me because in the end
there is an answer if you disagree with
department or you disagree with me stand
stand against us use The Ballot Box
please don't try and intimidate don't
try and pursue us through evil means
whether that's through death or whatever
it is because all it will do will unite
poem parliament's at its best when it's
being attacked brings us together and it
will never succeed democracy will always
succeed I want to start off before we
talk about Parliament and politics and
what's been going on lately about your
family because your family is steeped in
politics your dad Doug was a member of
parliament a labor MP for what is now
largely the Pendle constituency in
Lancashire he became an MP in 1974. you
were just 17 years old do you remember
your first visit here with him I do and
used to come down quite a lot it's
interesting isn't it and during that
time you know to be an MP labor
government you know and it it was
strange wasn't it because it was always
on the edge and you know you're heading
towards how long could the government
last and that was always going to be the
difficult thing
um and in the end it was brought down
you know it's amazing when you loot By
1979 suddenly got a job then you're out
of a job yeah so I've seen what it's
like
um you know when when you're employed
you give everything up to become an MP
and then you're rejected you know that
that's the nature of democracy but it
comes as a shock and it was obviously a
shock to the family that suddenly he was
no longer a mental retirement and he was
then looking for a job and then he came
but he came back didn't he was very
lucky he came back in the very famous
by-election
um of course the STP had been formed Roy
Jenkins you know the big beast of the
labor party were knowing their own party
and the first challenge for them was
Warrington and the Warrington violation
came up and he managed to win it so so
you thought about your Dad tried to
become an MP for 10 years became an MP
then lost his seat a few months later
then got a seat back but it didn't put
you off you didn't think God this is it
must have been as a Teenage his son it
must have been actually quite a
stressful time for your family but it
didn't put you off well the school's
like everything you go through stages
don't you you know I'll never forget the
1964 election when he was fighting
clitheroe you know this was the run here
are my 1963 very cold winter going
putting leaflets through doors you know
there's this youngster very enthusiastic
realizing and then you think why was I
doing that you know enthusiasm of a
young child is very easy and running up
to the doors putting lethalers through
you know that that was thy early
introduction you go through life and I
think what brings your background to
politics you're absolutely right you see
what happens to a family and it's about
where are you at that moment
I felt you know to be a counselor on
surely it was absolutely everything I
wanted to do young used to have a
counselor elected to chill there was on
there I loved every minute of it I was
the mayor of the Town I'd be Deputy
leader I'd help nearly every position on
the council and people said to me
Lindsay you know the leader a friend of
mine said Lou what do you think about
Charlie why can't we have a labor MP
that is from Charlie and in the end they
persuaded me and I managed to get
selected and of course the rest became
history in 1997 labor Landslide and
suddenly I'm I'm the new MP for Charlie
and then
um when when we came to the deputy
speaker because suddenly yeah they're
going to have elected Deputy speakers
and I thought do I stay on the select
committee what do I do Labor's now in
opposition
um Nigel Evan said to me why don't we
both realm to become Deputy speaker is
going to be elected because nobody's
going to tap either as on the shoulders
by the way do you want this job because
that's how it used to be but with
election it's like the different I know
to win elections marginal seats so I
thought yeah I'm gonna go with this
so we both decided to stand and they got
elected just before I move on just in
terms of when you're the speaker you
have to be a political
you'll see steeped in labor politics you
know you were doing it from the age of
five is that heart it's genuinely is
that hard to do or do you just leave it
at the door when you take the seat
I always believe in this that
I've been the mayor where you had to be
neutral as well at surely so of course
you don't give up your membership for
the party but of course in 2010 I became
Deputy speaker so you had to assure
neutrality within the church even though
I'm a labor MP but I always say this
when you go for speaker you know what
the rules are if you can't accept the
rules don't yeah do it fair play and
that's and that's the point that I
always take on board if you're going to
do it I accept the rules get on with it
and that's what but when you go back to
Chorley
um is it hard because people will want
you to Advocate on the cost of living I
mean number one are your constituents
finding it hard at the moment and number
two is it hard not to advocate for them
here
I'm always there for my constituents
because I always say this I'm the
trolley MP first of the speaker second
so where am I going I'll be off up that
road tomorrow I'll be on the train I'll
get to chorely I'll be doing the usual
any meetings the new twin I'll be doing
my surgery I'll be beating my
constituents taking up the issues
listening to the issues the same on
Saturday different events in the morning
uh of course I'll go out selling poppies
uh you know that matters to me I'm part
of that Community I'm in the heart of
the community and I'm so visible and
accessible and the UC insulins are you
seeing the hardship is it getting worse
for people in your constituency at the
moment it's getting hard for everybody
yeah and let's look at what's going to
happen interest rates mortgages those
are the big issues whether people can
afford the heating food you know
Charlie's a wealthy constituency it's
very wealthy and yet we have food banks
and that tells you it's it's about the
community and we mustn't forget about
that part of the community you know
we've got this huge rural Countryside
around me but in the heart of that I've
got the same problems in this city and
what I've got is an ability to try and
make a real difference because when I
want to see somebody I may not ask it on
the floor of the house but if I want to
see a prime minister a prime minister
comes to see me I want to see a
secretary of state to come see me so the
issues of childing God direct to a
secretary of state or to a prime
minister so being an advocate on behalf
of my constituents I've got the access I
will never have if I wasn't a speaker so
you sort of have behind the scenes
influence very much big big influence
but you just can't publicly speak I
don't publicly some say I do say a
little bit from the church but have you
raised issues of cost of living then
with Liz truss slash Boris Johnson slash
Rishi sunac what what I would say is
we're going through the motions though
I'm trying to keep up with the changes I
think that's nice
you know because you have conversations
with ministers and I've been dealing
with some you know about disability
access at the railway station so I'm no
one third minister in the space of weeks
and that's always a problem and of
course the Health Service really the
matter is the a e at short and of course
the new secretary of state that's now
being booked in all the meetings I need
the business secretary I'll be having a
meeting with because these are the areas
that matter businesses how are they
going to continue you know heavy uses of
energy so so taking up because they're
employers so big employees so as a local
MP and take your speaker hat off now if
you can but as a local MP the turmoil in
Parliament and the turmoil in
Westminster has been a problem for
constituents and getting things done
that's fair to say is it well I think
all MPS quite rightly represent the
constituents if constituents have got
the issues I'm always going to raise
those issues is how we raise them yeah
and the what I do and the churn of the
churn at the moment is like everything
uh we should now hopefully have a
settled period again nobody ever
expected and I talked to politicians of
all political parties journalist
everybody and I say one thing
have you ever seen anything like this
and did you expect it and we all have
one thing in common we've never seen
anything like it before and nobody
expected the churn that we've seen did
it make you feel angry
I'm not a person who gets angry very
easily well though it says I get upset
because in the end it's about the people
of this country
you know you've got a government that's
been elected they also need to get on
and quite rightly deliver on behalf of
all other constituents because in the
end they're the people that are going to
suffer and we've got to look after them
and now stability is what we need there
isn't going to be an election
um unless somebody tells me something
different with the majority like that
they are the elected government and as
much as people say who demanded general
election I can't see that happening just
yet but in the meantime we've got to
recognize people out there are
struggling and that's for the government
to deliver on and I I genuinely believe
that the people this country need a good
representation I think and hope that
we're going into a very calm period
let's get on to Parliament a bit in some
of the what's been going on a bit if we
may I mean you just said that kind of
what's been happening in recent months
you felt upset you felt upset because of
the way in which it was impacting on
real life for for your constituents
right when government isn't functioning
and your role is to represent Parliament
and MPS in some way Beyond this place
that that's kind of how I I see part of
what you do and some of the goings-on
just didn't look good did they and what
before we go in we might even go there
but just in just what's happened
recently just in terms of Matt Hancock
the former Health secretary he's not
here in Parliament working on behalf of
his constituents he's out in the jungle
in on Australia and I'm on a celeb what
what did you think of that
but it's not what I think it's what it's
constituents think because they're the
people that matter we're elected to
represent those people they voted for it
and they will have the answer yeah they
have the answer for politicians if you
don't like it they'll get rid of us and
that's where he will be answerable he
will come back and he will last answer
to his constituents he has made that
decision not for two years well who
knows they we don't know any election
will be
um like everything it could be any
during that period and of course his own
party have decided to discipline as well
so what I will say is
I loop from here and say his
constituents will make their voice out
they all met their feelings not and in
the end you've got to put your concerns
what do you think about it though come
on what that's not what I think about
him what I do I think is a better
question and the answer is I remember
that am I going to go running around a
gentle eating kangaroos testicles
absolutely not no no it's the answer I
wouldn't do it
do you don't think he should have done
it or you don't want to say that he's
got to look into his own constituents
okay and that's in furnace to my uncle
he's his answer lies with the people who
reaction what I would say is the
question is would I do it the answer
would be no you wouldn't do it and just
one other thing on that just because
it's been easy in terms of what the
publishing again Boris Johnson on
holiday uh when Parliament sit in should
MPS be allowed to take time off to go on
holiday when you get quite long recess
periods I know MP's work in recess but
what do you think of that do you think
that should be loud what would I would
say is Luke in the end I'm not going to
get into personalities of individuals
and people work in different ways and
you say we've had a long recess well
most MPS are working through the recess
I know and some didn't get holidays
we've had the tragedy of a Majesty dying
in the middle of it the fact that the
whole thing's changed and if you've been
a prime minister and other jobs as well
you are on a 24-hour seven-day call and
I've got some sympathy say you know he's
been the Prime Minister he's with his
family when will they see them and in
the end you know he's taking a decision
that what he needs to do is his own
health his family whatever and I don't
want to start picking on individuals
that wouldn't be right of me because in
the end we all come back to one thing we
have to face the people who elect us and
I want to talk a bit about if if you if
you were okay with this about the people
uh the elect MPS and kind of
how Parliament has been in the past
couple of years because I would argue
that it's not been a particularly
edifying period And I say that because
we've had two prime ministers Boris
Johnson Rishi sooner both find by the
police for for breaking those lockdown
regulations we've got MPS under
investigation for Lobby and today Andrew
Bridgeman has been recommended for a
suspension party gate the pinch refer do
you accept that it's been a bad year for
standards in public life and does that
concern you of course it concerns me
anything that tarnishes this is not good
for anybody and it's about the behavior
people loot to politicians they look for
leadership and you know um I won't go
into the details of individuals because
I've not even read the report what they
would say is we want a better Parliament
we want a nice upon we want a tolerance
with impact but also we need to respect
each other if we don't respect each
other and we don't set the high AI
standards that people expect of us how
do we expect that respect and if we
shouted each other don't be shocked when
other people shout back at you on the
outside because we set we should be the
role models that people look to because
in the end we're elected to represent
our constituents and we should represent
them with the highest standards and
that's what's important but but it
doesn't see I guess my point to you sir
Lindsay and I've been at this for 12
years I've been in and around
Westminster and still we have reports I
mean Sky News did a podcast recently
called The Open Secret and it would it
uncovered to be some bullying in
Parliament accounts of sexual harassment
including young staff has been forced to
scrub carpets screamed at demeaned it's
been you know I remember pessminster
that was five years ago
um it's like it's almost like time ticks
on
and we're still having these
conversations why why does it not
improve well are you powerless to
improve it I I think we've got to
improve absolutely right and we have
done things to ensure that people can
come forward what I would say is we have
no the ability for people to build to
report without intimidation and to be
assessed independently
and that's the one thing that we've
ensured that is a way forward for staff
to be able to report something without
having to go to the boss because
technically it was 650 bosses within MPS
so we have the independence now for
people where they will feel that the
more empowered and what I would do is
encourage people and maybe we see more
of it because people now are reporting
it where previously they wouldn't that's
it and it's about bringing us to a point
and I would say to anybody Luke
we've got some serious allegations
please
we have the different route if it's
Sears go straight to the place yeah
absolutely please report that and we do
support people within the house and we
want to make sure that they feel safe I
want this to be a workplace and it's not
easy but I want this to be a workplace
that's respected we've been trying to
ensure that people are treated fairly
and making sure there is recognition and
respect for everybody who works within
this house and that's what matters if
you're a pass holder you can respect it
we've got to make sure that everybody's
looked after not just about MPS it's
about MP staff and it's about staff of
the house they matter to me and it's
about that independence of being built
to report it and and that is a new
develop well not but a few years old the
the ability
yeah exactly you signed it off and now
it is in place but
you know there was an MP uh that was
accused and has just been
found to have sexually harassed a member
of staff and that case went on for 17
months and the MP was still wandering
around the houses of Parliament now in
another organization if those sorts of
allegations happen the person is not
just moving
amongst people whilst investigations are
underway I mean do you do you think that
should change I mean
we're not saying nobody's told about it
you can't text loads yeah but that
because it was the investigation so we
don't know that I'm not told of
Investigation right okay that the one
thing is that it was taken quite rightly
rather than the speaker being involved
it was an independent body that was set
up to look into and investigate and it's
hard for me to want to write to 17
months I don't know but I would say is
we need to make that I want it
shortening I want quick answers to when
people make complaints we want quick
investigations would you like more
powers to go off to do more
I think would you what could because it
seems to me that things aren't improving
quickly enough
I think my degree and I'm asking for a
review as you know I've set up a review
at the moment I am looking and taking
evidence from stuff and quite rightly
about should MPS employ stuff I should
do not is there a hybrid is there
somewhere for for them to turn what is
the best weather we're Gathering that
evidence in and I want to make sure that
we take that evidence we look at it and
we make decisions and those decisions
are so important what we come out with
those recommendations will be put to the
floor of the house because part of that
could be should an MP be excluded I
haven't got the power to explain
somebody I was gonna that would that
that's the key to this investigation
that people will give their evidence and
pass that evidence could be looter so
what I would say is that it will open up
in different ways that we will look at
it we will present it and decisions will
have to be met some of them will be
tough decisions for the house to make
but it's quite right that we should give
the house that chance to do something
about this what's a problem so Lindsay
just just what if I come back and we
have this conversation in three years
say mid-2025
will it be better in terms of Conduct in
the House of Commons and the complaints
procedures and sanctions will it be
better and if it isn't would you have
thought you have failed as the speaker
what I would say is I'm going to do
everything I can to support the people
who work within this building this is a
village we want a good Village what a
good place to work I want people to make
sure not only do you feel safe here but
actually say to other people that's a
great place to work you need to go and
work in the House of Commons whether
that's a politician with its staff
whether you work for an MP whatever it's
about getting it right what I would say
is I'm going to make sure that the voice
of those people are heard we're going to
report into it and I hope that the house
would respect the evidence that we've
been given and we'll take that decision
on board what I will say is it's a major
challenge I'm not going to stop and
we've got to keep Reviving
looking at it changing it altering it
whatever we need to do we've got to get
in the right place and now we'll do
whatever we can to get the house in the
right place and that's my key because
because just just to go on to what you
were saying about whether MP should be
expelled I mean there is no way that an
MP can be expelled at the moment I mean
in other Industries if you
have gross misconduct in any which way
you can be struck off from practicing as
a doctor or a lawyer or a financial
services practitioner but MPS there are
no do you think that's wrong because the
public might think it's wrong I wonder
what you think well that's why I've set
up the committed to look into this what
do you think my view is that in a
serious position and that's why I've
worked very closely with the whips
whereas serious allegation made they are
not coming onto their stand so I'm very
clear on that and I will continue to
ensure that that happens and we have
done everything we can if he gives us
the power it will be much easier without
the power I work very closely with the
whips and we eventually
that the people who were fishing those
serious allegations do not come on this
day I think that's a very clear position
from me and I've been very effective in
making sure that has happened and and so
Lindsay in terms of just one other thing
on this and then I'm going to move on in
times of the privileged committee as
well misleading the house allies of the
former prime minister Mr Johnson think
it's time to move on from the peripheral
it's committee investigation to whether
he misled Parliament but presumably for
you it's vital that a judgment is made
on whether he did because if from your
point of view sitting in that chair
and Parliament being sovereign
is there a more serious parliamentary
offense than misleading MPS that's why
the house of us have asked for the
investigation and the committee on
privilege of looking into it and that's
very clear that's not my decision that's
a house decision and I will always
respect the house decision and that's
the decision dictate so what I would say
is that report is ongoing yeah and that
report will be delivered and not because
I said it it's because the house said it
but I'm a servant of the house and I
respect the decision the house what I'm
asking you more broadly is again about
sanctions at the moment if an MP
misleads the house the sanction is being
suspended what I'm saying to you is do
you think that that is a big enough
sanction and this is not about that case
that's just in general but in general
each case is different and it is at what
level you get to and what I would say is
you would judge each case and what has
happened you would take the evidence and
you make an informed decision and what
we don't do is take it lightly to Mr
lead the house is very serious it's
whether it's deliberate or not just
another huge question for you as we
return to Guy Fawkes and his scheme to
try and blow up Parliament is that the
palace is at risk of burning down today
it just in terms of the renovations you
must be so worried about that happening
on your watch aren't you
I'm always worried about anything
happening in this building and fire of
course is one of our own number one
threat to this building and that's why
I've been trying to encourage and trying
to work with everybody say what we need
is a myth system right across the whole
of the buildings because that's the key
to stopping fire spreading because what
we have got we've put all the fire
systems in to save life but of course we
have to save the building so I've asked
for a review on the implementation of
putting the Smith system in that could
be isolated to a fire may take place to
stop the fire spray those are the kind
of things we need to do I want us to get
on with it I want us to deliver they've
done it in the Congress because they're
fire wardens on 24-hour Patrol there's
been 60 fires in the last decade it
could become the next Notch of Dome I
mean well that's not quite true because
scare you though I think what we've got
to watch people throw Notre Dame and
Windsor at me what it would say is they
were both empty and that was when you
had contractors on so let's compare the
two what I would say it's the reason we
have fire ones on is to check for fire
the fact is that when you've got
instructions you're more likely to lose
a building hence Notre Dame was not the
building being in news far from it it
was being renovated the same with
Windsor and what I would say is that's
why I want to get the Miss system in now
so if you start doing the building Works
you've got the fire suppressed just
quickly a missed system in now but the
latest plan is for the laws to vacate
and the commons to move to the Lords
while the renovations take place in a
vacated chamber is that your preferred
solution I don't even know of this
solution no absolutely not because we've
not even got to that first of all we
don't know where the lodge would go to
and the second thing is that we're still
in the planning of what we need to do so
we're still waiting for the reports to
come back that's why I want to get on
with this suppression system using a
Miss system to protect this building
while people are talking and you're
normally doing the building works just
one thing your legacy what's the most
important thing for you is it the
conduct and improving conduct and and
this being a good place to work for
people is it protecting the building of
equal importance for your legacy the
role of equal importance but what really
bothers me is the stuff of this building
the MPS is looking after them being a
champion for all who come to this
building and of course the both top of
my list so Lindsay thank you so much for
your time I appreciate it well thank you
to my special guest there sir Lindsay
Hoyle and if you scan this QR code on
your screen right now you can watch all
of our interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show if you so
desire well that's it for tonight thank
you so much for watching and I hope that
we'll see you next week
[Music]